[Music]
[Applause]
president biden in the white house being
accused of giving quote cover for
communists
over their response to the mass protests
in cuba
thousands of people there chanting
freedom and down with communism
while marching in the streets but the
bond administration is blaming the
unrest on
coven cases and deaths the president
finally getting around to reacting to
the situation
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and we call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba and it's been
crickets from
self-described socialists like bernie
sanders and aoc
they're quick to bash america but so far
have yet to condemn the communist regime
and take a look at how white house press
secretary jensachi carefully avoid
saying the word communism
there's every indication that
yesterday's protests were
spontaneous expressions of people who
were exhausted with the cuban
government's economic mismanagement
and repression and those these are
protests inspired by the harsh reality
of everyday life
in cuba not people in another country
economic mismanagement aka communism
so dana perino it's funny now you don't
say communism the liberals say
authoritarianism and it's funny because
that was the exact same word they used
to describe president trump
who was the polar opposite of a
communist yep and i think i do feel like
the white house got to a better place
today than they were yesterday and
like with some stronger statements
including from the president and the
press secretary
while the protests had just started they
had i think like the deputy secretary of
western hemisphere like they're the only
ones that said something and jake
sullivan said something from
the white house from national security
advisor not good enough but i do think
that
this white house learned a little bit
about supporting
dissidents and freedom movements after
what happened with
iran and the green movement and we
didn't do anything
during the obama administration and they
took a lot of heat for that and actually
never
i don't think they ever really got over
that so i think that they they finally
got there but what's also interesting is
that
the initial response is that oh this is
covid it's because of accidents
and now that there could be some of that
but i also think it's very interesting
that i
didn't know about um some of this pop
culture stuff that's going on down there
it's often
artists that will push forward and
there's a rapper named i gotta read it
michael asorbo and he's quoted as saying
people are
tired and they can't take it anymore and
a lot of his work has been
really pushing people to think about
their conditions and part of the
spontaneity is that
there's young people there who want a
better life the other thing i think that
you see
the white house weighing in a little bit
more strongly today than they did
yesterday is that democrats see florida
slipping away as an option permanently
yeah so
greg i thought socialism was great the
health care system was terrific in cuba
why would they be upset
with the covent situation there then i
don't know they got a hell of an
education system too
but i will say this it probably is
better than ours at this point
um you know the thing is uh it i think
right now
this is one example of showing how
foreign policy
doesn't really matter right now and not
just for our white house
but for our media and for our culture in
general when you think about what's
going on right now right so you got this
stuff going on in cuba
you we just had an assassination in
haiti you got china making aggressive
moves
in in you know all over the place you
got russia and ransomware which is
basically cyber warfare
and now we have this cuba stuff but our
press is doing all their trench
reporting
in in the culture war we are now so
obsessed about
our past and litigating our past that
we're not looking around and we're not
looking at our future
and what could happen next these are the
battles that are currently being fought
but we believe that the battle is over
non-binary toilets
right and pronouns and i i sound like
i'm getting but
we are spending an inordinate amount of
inordinate in ornament this is important
thank you
important uh um amount of time
um reckoning with our past
as opposed to understanding what i mean
imagine
you know if you think about pre-world
war ii if we were obsessing over the
things we were obsessing in america what
would have happened
you know would we have ever uh would
have engaged
the the germans or the japanese or
anything it would have
we would have been you know what we're
not able to do that right now because
you know billy doesn't feel right well
we never would have dropped the a-bomb
on
the japanese and that probably would
have cost millions more american lives
so what is with this just knee-jerk
reaction everything's covered jessica
they see anything in the world covid oh
covet sorry covet
i mean is that all we have once sooner
or later kobe's going to be gone what
are they going to blame next
never going to be gone never going to be
going to be a variant it's going to be
the cuban variant yes
that's tasty well you are correct about
that we're never going to get rid of
cobit we have to learn to live with it
which we have mostly by this point which
is a very good thing but
jensaki also managed uh also mentioned
economic mismanagement i know you would
prefer that she
you know was screaming socialism or
communism foreign communism do you think
i'm pretty sure she would and i'm pretty
sure that she has said it but i think
that
the argument that the white house is
trying to make and i really agree with
dana that today
seemed near perfect i obviously haven't
been a press secretary myself but the
statement that the biden would house put
out this morning
tony blinken also commented on this to
make sure that everyone knew because the
cuban government is saying that the u.s
is fomenting this that we have no role
whatsoever
in causing this uprising and it's there
are people that are upset
with how the regime works i think we've
been forceful we've been
allies to them we're saying we support
you in your you know your cause
your desire for freedom to live free of
an authoritarian and
authoritarians come in many packages
they come in communist packages and they
come in
putin-like packages now they come in
packages like an assad
and so i don't really see a problem with
calling them that
the problem is is that it neglected to
talk about the why
you cannot talk about the people in the
street and not talk about the
cuban americans that are here when i was
on the campaign trail i spent a lot of
time in florida
and it was very clear that the latino
vote was shifting because of the
socialism
and it's one thing to read about these
stories and history books
but if you sit down with those cuban
americans that are in the united states
right now
and they tell you the broken promises
there was they believed it
and it broke them and they came to
america as a result
and so i think what was tone deaf is
that the president
and the press secretary didn't really
speak to that audience and say
we hear you we hear the people that are
on the street and we know the cause of
that that's why the word matters
yeah and it was a missed opportunity was
that a banned phrase missed opportunity
am i allowed to say that i think you are
allowed to say it but you're only out
one
one time okay hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else